Mind your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
Suppose two lines intersect in the interior of the circle.
If the measure of this arc of the circle is equal to 80°,
and the measure of this arc of the circle is equal to 140°,
what is the value of ∠X where the two lines intersect?
Pause the video, if you'd like to give this problem a try,
and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
So, how can we solve this problem?
The key is constructing a chord of the circle between the two intersecting lines.
Let's see why this helps.
Consider this 80° arc.
Notice, between this chord and a line, we've constructed an inscribed angle of the circle.
Therefore, the measure of this inscribed angle would be 1/2 of 80°, which is equal to 40°.
Similarly, for the other arc, we've constructed an inscribed angle of the circle.
Therefore, the measure of this angle will be equal to 70°.
Putting these two facts together,
we now consider the two intersecting lines and this constructed triangle.
This angle X is an exterior angle of the triangle;
therefore, its value will be equal to 70° + 40°, which is equal to 110°.
Another way of seeing this
is that the remaining angle in the triangle is equal to 70°, to get a total sum of
180°, and then X = 180° - 70°, which is equal to
110°, and that's our answer.
Thanks for making Mind your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube.
As always, thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.